vous souvenez-vous de votre premier
baiser les papillons la chaleur la
texture des lèvres il paraît qu'on s'en
souvient mieux que de notre première
fois mais quelle est la science derrière
ce geste pourquoi ma coup on s'est dit
je vais mettre ma bouge ta bouche et ça
sera un signe d'amour est ce qu'on
observe son comportement dans des tribus
humaine éloignés ou chez les animaux ce
qui laisserait penser à un rôle
biologique et si c'était le cas ça sert
à quoi on va voir si la science peut
nous aider à comprendre pourquoi on
s'embrasse quelle est l'origine
historique du baiser dans les années 60
des chercheurs ont lancé une grande
étude qui a conclu que oui le baiser est
universel tout le monde y croyait
jusqu'en 2015 quand on a refait l'étude
avec une meilleure méthodologie sur 168
culture humaine seuls 46% pratique le
baiser romantique certes 46 %
représentent 90 % de l'humanité mais non
c'est pas universelle leurs travaux ont
aussi montré que plus une culture est
complexe plus elle est adepte du baiser
la cause serait nos vêtements qui font
des lèvres la seule que atteignable pour
un échange sensuelle et donc un lieu
d'excitation et ça semble se confirmer
quand on observe des tribus de chasseurs
cueilleurs ou les vêtements sont absents
pas trouvé beaucoup de sources mais dans
les quelques sociétés étudiées le baiser
romantique qui était absent certaines
cultures pense même que ça peut aspirer
votre âme peut-on conclure dès lors que
les hommes préhistoriques ne se soit
jamais embrassée
non car aussi primitive soit ces tribus
elles ont aussi évolué avec le temps et
peut-être que le baiser s'est perdue
alors qu'elle est la plus ancienne trace
historique de cette pratique en a
quelques hiéroglyphes égyptiens ont
représentants des adultes proches mais
l'élève se touchent pas les vraies
premières traces de baiser se trouvent
dans des inscriptions adou vieille de
3500 ans ça serait d'ailleurs pendant
ces grandes conquêtes qu'alexandre le
grand séduit par cette pratique
l'important en europe ça on n'en dit pas
sûr c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas de
trace écrite que ça n'existait pas avant
d'ailleurs la bible hébraïque fait
référence un bees amoureux qu'on peut
dater ou 3e siècle avant jésus-christ et
ça avait l'air d'être déjà une norme
amoureuse c'est vraiment avec les
romains que le baiser va devenir une
institution le suave y sommes baiser des
amants avec la langue le base y sommes
en famille et law school sommes entre
copains oui et ça existe encore
aujourd'hui en russie en europe de l'est
s'embrasser entre garçons sur la bouche
est un signe de respect tout à fait et
véro ça se faisait aussi au moyen âge
entre chevaliers et j'ai l'impression
partout dans le monde en fait pendant
une grande partie de notre histoire le
baiser sur la bouche n'avait pas la
connotation sexuelle qu'on lui connaît
aujourd'hui pensez-y y a pas encore si
longtemps un père qui embrassait sa
petite fille sur la bouche ça choqué
personne aujourd'hui ça met très mal à
l'aise voire c'est criminalise abl alors
du coup le baiser serait une pure
invention culturel sans aucun sous
jacent naturel ce qui nous amène à la
question les animaux sans bras style si
les animaux pratique aussi le baiser ça
veut dire que ce serait un truc
instinctif un comportement inné il ya
beaucoup d'espèces qui ont l'air de
s'embrasser les souris et les écureuils
bros leur nez les tortues se donne une
petite tape sur la tête les félins se
lèchent entre eux et les girafes entre
l'as leurs coûts oui mais est-ce qu'on
donne la bonne signification à ces
comportements un moment il y avait un
couple de pigeons qui venait toujours à
ma fenêtre c'était toujours les mêmes
ils étaient en couple puisque les
pigeons sont monogames et j'avais
l'impression qu'ils s'embrassent et il
se frottait le bec comme ça trop mignon
en vrai c'est pas une marque d'affection
tel qu'on l'entend chez les humains le
mal est en fait en train de filer de la
bouffe à la femelle pour lui montrer
qu'il sera capable de la nourrir elle
est leur futur petit hoquet un oiseau
c'est loin d'un humain alors regardons
plutôt nos proches cousins les bonobos
chez eux après une dispute entre deux
individus on s'embrasse sur la bouche
avec la lampe pour se re concis chez les
chimpanzés ça va encore plus loin se
dire bonjour se traduite carrément par
un acte sexuel chercher chez des animaux
un baiser originel est une sacrée erreur
tout n'est pas instinctif chez les
animaux ils ont des cultures des
comportements acquis qu'ils reproduisent
en voyant les autres faire même somme
biaisé par nos perceptions culturelles
regardez ces petits poissons c'est
mignon ils font des petits bisous non
pas en fait c'est carrément de
l'agressivité alors quand s'arrête notre
interprétation et quand commence la
science en même temps c'est assez
compliqué de demander aux animaux
pourquoi tu touches la trompe alors
puisque ni l'histoire ni la zoologie ne
semble avoir d'explication si on
regardait aux côtés de la biologie
pourquoi on s'embrasse selon la biologie
il y a trois grandes théories avancées
par la science 1 la becquée le tout
petit qui n'a pas de dents ne peut
manger que de la purée alors avant
l'invention du terme au x ces moments
qui s'y coller elle prenait de la
nourriture dans sa bouche la mâcher et
la régurgiter dans la bouche du bébé on
appelle ça le baiser d'alimentation
oiseaux insectes et humains utilisent
cette technique le baiser amoureux
viendrait alors de cette époque où
sentir les lèvres de quelqu'un contre
les siennes signifier nourriture
sécurité et bien être à éviter quand
même on ait deux le reniflage informatif
un individu dégage des phéromones les
odeurs qui vont lui être propre elles
sont en fonction de l'âge de la bonne
santé du sexe de la période de fertilité
et d'un tas d'autres choses nos ancêtres
avant d'avoir inventé la parole pour
expliquer leur attention se renifler de
très près pour détecter ces informations
tu veux un deck avec moi laisse moi te
sentir d'abord d'un reniflements
rapprocher nez contre nez on serait
alors passé un baiser bouche contre
bouche quand lolf actifs est devenu has
been 3 la couleur de nos lèvres ouais
c'est pas la meilleure théorie mais les
lèvres comme les muqueuses ayant la
couleur des fruits bien mûrs et
nutritifs nous aurions une appétence
pour ces dernières ce qu'on peut en
embrassant ce se gorger de l'autre comme
on croque ray une pêche bien juteuses
sur un marché d'été problème c'est trois
théories ne nous lisent toujours pas
pourquoi on garde cette pratique plus
personne ne crache de la nourriture dans
la bouche de son bébé question
phéromones on voit que ça ne joue
quasiment plus et enfin niveau fruits on
traite plus vraiment la dalle à quoi ça
sert de s'embrasser biologiquement
parlant un baiser vaut beaucoup mieux
que mille mots vos lèvres s'entrelacent
vous goûtez santé c'est fluide ce qui
vous livre plein d'informations
essentielles pour mieux connaître votre
partenaire dans la nature ça a son
importance le mâle veuve noire arrive à
sentir si la femelle afin rien qu'avec
les féroe mode qu'elle dégage plutôt
pratique sachant que la femelle dévore
le mal si on a un petit creux mieux vaut
éviter de approché dans ces cas là
contrairement à l'idée reçue l'humain a
un sens de l' odorat très développé on
peut sentir une gouttelette de
substances puantes diluée dans
l'équivalent de deux piscines certaines
personnes comme cette dame arrive même à
sentir les maladies ce qu'on pensait
n'être qu'un super pouvoirs du chien si
le dorat humain a si mauvaise réputation
c'est qu'il serait incapable de sentir
les phéromones stress désir peur colère
un chien le sang à nous enfin ça c'est
en théorie certes notre organe
voméronasal est complètement atrophiée
mais il est quand même là et certains
chercheurs pensent qu'il est encore
faiblement actifs c'est la fameuse étude
du tee shirt mouillé des hommes et des
femmes ont porté pendant trois jours un
tee shirt sans parfum et ils devaient
classer l'attractivité des odeurs
étonnamment les hommes semblait préférer
les femmes qui étaient en phase de
violation il y avait même une petite
corrélation avec le fait qu'une personne
trop proche de nous génétiquement nous
attire moins plutôt pratique pour éviter
la consanguinité
du coup s'approcher pour s'embrasser
serait une sorte de flemmen humain le
phénomène c'est le nom qu'on donne à la
posture que prennent les animaux en
recherche de signes aux terreaux mono
ouais c'est un peu ridicule là en tout
cas si ça joue pas sur l'odorat ça joue
très certainement dans la salive il ya
aussi des hormones comme la testostérone
la salive des hommes en contient et la
famille est sensible la paroisse où la
langue est en très fines l'hormone va
pouvoir passer très vite dans le sang
des essais sont même en cours pour
booster la libido des femmes ménopausées
avec un spray buccal à la testostérone
au delà de l'excitation c'est aussi un
bon moyen de connaître l'état de santé
de votre partenaire on estime qu'on
échange une cuillère à café de salive
lors d'un baiser langoureux et la salive
c'est pas que de l'eau on a droit à
toutes les bactéries du partenaire
environ 80 millions de bactéries changer
pour un baiser de dix secondes cette son
type de bactéries différentes
ne criez pas au drame une poignée de
main c'est près de dix mille milliards
mais sans aller chercher aussi loin une
simple haleine fraîche pourra toujours
plus envie qu'une allen malades cada
verrines odeur de poisson ou de pommes
pourries c'est des symptômes de maladie
qui vous repousse naturellement si c'est
intellectuellement stimulant de chercher
des explications complexes à pourquoi on
s'embrasse la vérité pourrait être un
peu plus décevant c'est juste que c'est
agréable tout part de ce bonhomme à nos
mômes +106 tiff en gros plus la partie
du corps est grosse plus elle est
sensible au toucher plus le nom de
connexions nerveuses et grands vous avez
vu la taille des lèvres c'est une des
zones les plus sensibles de notre
anatomie encore plus que sous la
ceinture et c'est normal c'est par là
qu'on mange une plante qui nous brûle un
insecte inpix est un signal qu'il faut
recraché mais quand c'est agréable que
c'est doux c'est que ça doit être bon
pour vous alors vous avez droit votre
shoot de dopamine le baiser n'est-il
donc une pratique culturelle arrivé au
hasard ou répond-t-il à un besoin
biologique est inné la science n'a pas
de réponse définitive
et c'est étonnant quand on voit
l'importance qu'a cette pratique chez
nous même dans des sociétés très
technologique regardez cette à paris
pour se faire des bisous à distance
certes là vous n'avez pas d'information
génétique mais vous savez déjà que votre
9 et crépy
et que penser de ce site de rencontres
qui propose d'analyser votre adn à
partir de salive pour trouver le
partenaire
génétiquement idéal 2000 $ l'inscription
alors que comme on vient de le voir il
suffit de tendre vos lèvres à l'inconnu
oui en amour comme en sciences la
sérendipité est ce qu'il ya de meilleur
[Musique]